welcome everybody to uh what is session
23 in this series a quarterly series
called philosophers in the midst of
History which we've been doing here at
the Frank wanberg Library since uh 2016
we had to take a Hiatus when you all
remember the coid lockdown and we
couldn't do anything and then we we came
back and started doing these again and
and um this is a like I said a quarterly
Series so we'll we'll have a session
each year in February May August and
then November like we're doing here and
this is a little bit out of sequence
because usually what we do is an ancient
philosopher in the spring and then a
medieval philosopher in May and then a
early modern philosopher in August and
then we wrap up the year with somebody
from like the 19th or 20th century in in
November now David Hume almost made it
to the 19th century but didn't quite get
there he was about 20 well a little
little under 25 years short so we're
doing him in part because August I I got
sick so I couldn't be here for that so
we had to cancel that one so we're we're
doing that one um we've already got some
authors picked out for next year um I'm
looking at doing senica the stoic
philosopher
Peter abelard who's a great early
medieval figure well really mid-
medieval figure um Emanuel Kant great uh
uh 19th C well 18th 19th century um
mostly 18th century and then Irish
Murdoch who we we were planning on doing
this year but we didn't get to come on
in um so what we do in this series is I
talk for a while there's time for Q&A
not just at the end but at at different
points and you can you know ask
questions at any time if you want to I
can always get us back onto track um and
you know it it's sort of like what the
the title suggests we're looking at the
philosophers and their ideas but within
a historical context so how are they
shaped by the history that they were
involved in what role did they have in
it um what effects what influence did
they have afterwards and you know as it
turns out with David Hume I mean you
could say that in our present day um
he's you know he's very influential in
the world of ideas but not quite so much
say in the world of politics or
economics but he he actually was quite
important uh in his own time and a
little bit afterwards for those those
sorts of things so we'll we'll talk
about that briefly and as you notice we
we record these um you if you want to
you can go and check out all the earlier
ones they're available on on YouTube in
my channel Gregory B Sadler and um you
know they they actually interestingly
get a a good bit of views the I think
the one that has the least views it's
about 1,700 or so some of them have been
viewed like 20,000 times so we get a lot
of mileage out of this if you're if that
makes you reticent at all about asking
questions nobody's going to know who you
are so you don't have to worry about
that and you know as as teachers often
say there's no dumb questions um I don't
assume anybody has like a background in
this so if you've got a question you can
ask away and I will uh certainly be
happy to answer it so this guy David
Hume um how many of you have heard of
him
before okay so about half of you um he's
somebody who we still teach a lot in in
philosophy
classes and in a few other things maybe
if you take a class in Aesthetics you
might read some of his
essays um we don't really teach him much
in in other uh things although he he was
pretty important in his own time and he
was um not just a philosopher I mean he
actually wasn't really that well known
in his lifetime as a philosopher he was
better known as a historian he wrote a
six volume history of England that we'll
talk about in a bit
um he also was a a literary essayist you
know he what we nowadays would call like
a literary critic or a theorist and
that's where he actually made his
reputation and made made his money more
more importantly uh that's how he stayed
afloat his first main philosophy book as
he said fell stillborn from the Press he
was very disappointed with this the now
we actually recognize this as a work of
Genius but not a lot of people wanted to
buy it and back then
um you didn't go to a publisher
generally and have them like give you an
advance or something you went to a
publisher and said how much is it going
to cost me to get 40 you know copies or
500 copies of this bound ready to sell
in bookstores you had to be kind of
entrepreneurial so you know like quite a
few authors in our own time he was left
with uh quite a few extra copies for for
a
while um
he's from Scotland and you know nowadays
we we often think of Scotland as this
kind of quaint place north of England
that has beautiful Vistas and we think
about Braveheart which is you know very
anachronistic but in his time Scotland
was in some respects the place to be um
there was a lot of really interesting
stuff going on there it was it had
recently become part of the United
Kingdom which now you know includes four
kingdoms uh that took a while to to
bring together and that only happened in
in uh 1707 and Hume is born in
1711 so it's kind of a a new thing for
him and um there's all these conflicts
and Wars going on throughout the come on
in the course of his
lifetime and uh they're between major
and minor powers in Europe you know
Spanish were still a significant power
at the time the French of course uh
England combined with Scotland although
sometimes Scotland tried to you know
separate in ways that we'll we'll talk
about in a bit um Austria the
Netherlands even Sweden was kind of a uh
dominant power at the time although
going into eclipse and they were
fighting not just in Europe but
sometimes in the
Americas or over in India you know or in
uh other places fighting for trade
fighting for um religion fighting for
Prestige and uh that's kind of the
backdrop Italy Germany not unified
countries at the time as a matter of
fact just a whole bunch of little
scattered States although Germany is
kind of a Powerhouse by then in terms of
uh intellectual matters as we'll we'll
talk
about and um there's a lot of major
trans formations that are happening in
the society that Hume is is living in
not as quickly as in our time right I
mean if you think about just our last
decade and and the amazing uh
technological Transformations that we've
seen that's pretty striking um but you
know all sorts of other um
matters that are happening you know what
we nowadays call industrial society
capitalism is developing replac faing
earlier uh forms of of you know economic
exchange and
accumulation and Scotland is one of the
places where a lot of this stuff is is
happening um as a matter of fact
Edinburg is the center of what we call
the Scottish Enlightenment and Hume was
actually one of the not you know
founding members but but a a good part
of that and so that's that's part of the
culture that he's involved in the
enlightenment is also going on in the
other parts of England in France where
it's called the sea lumier in Germany
where it's called the AL claron you know
all of these are names for this
interesting uh set of developments that
are taking
place and it's um it's it's part of what
uh gets called eventually the Republic
of
letters so you know we think about our
current society and how you you know if
you want to you can go online and find
out about David Hume or anybody else you
know you can find videos and podcast
episodes and people teaching classes and
encyclopedia articles and that's really
awesome right and we have this wonderful
Road Network that got us all here today
that we often just take for granted you
know we were talking about how is
traffic on 43 ah it sucks you know and
there's these bottlenecks and you know
if you think about it there's nothing
for us to complain about it's amazing
we're living in the future David Hume
was living you know two centuries
earlier almost well two and a half
centuries earlier but they knew what
each other were thinking not because
they had telepathy or anything but
because they would write letters to each
other and the letters would actually get
to the places they were supposed to go
and they could copy them and not only
did they have letters they had salons
where you might go David hum
participated in the salon culture and in
par when he was there and they had you
know Publishers and the Publishers are
not just publishing books journals you
could read about the latest research not
just in philosophy but in science and
you could probably if you were educated
enough follow it and figure out what
these people were talking about and if
you you know if you thought that they
were wrong well you write them a letter
and you say here's where I think your
your experiment went to Ry or here's how
your philos ophy is off base and then
they would write you a letter back you
know sometimes the letter might be screw
off I'm not interested in talking with
you but very often it would be oh thank
you for pointing out these problems let
me see if I can address them and this is
part of the culture obviously it didn't
have the sort of rapidity that we have
now with email right where you can like
Tech you can easily contact
somebody um at any time you want to but
you know it was a real Improvement over
previous times and again Hume is is part
of that so he's getting to be a member
of the the world of ideas which is a
world that has important effects within
politics within culture within religion
and Society so I've given you a a
timeline that might be helpful for you
it's got when his Major Works were
published the things that he's doing in
his life and uh so I thought I'd you
know sort of run through that and it
also tells you about what other people
were doing that's that's of Interest it
helps us sort of situate him in the
history that he's living in some of
these are literary figures so you notice
the year that he's born Alexander pulp
publishes this essay on criticism a very
important uh work for
Aesthetics and you've got some political
things as well you know Kings dying in
being replaced by other
monarchs um various Wars taking place
and and all of that so Hume is born in
1711 in Edinburg uh he's he's actually
born as David Holm Hume is not his
original name he's going to change that
a little bit later on and you know like
a lot of kids at the time there wasn't
like a public school system that you
would go to so you you'd learn things at
home they could hire tutors for you uh
but eventually when um 1723 and he's
pretty young you know 12 years old at
the time he starts taking classes at the
University of Edinburg and taking
classes for us when we think about going
to college it's very structured process
right you gotta apply and then you get
in and then they want your money and
then uh what else happens you got to go
to the registar or you do it online
nowadays what classes am I going to take
your advisor you know back when I was
doing it had to sign a card now it's
just like a checkbox or something like
that and uh you couldn't just like
wander in and sit in people's classes
things were a little less regulated back
then so long as you weren't really
causing trouble and you could pay when
you were supposed to you know you and
and you seem like you understood what
you were doing they they'd let you learn
things and uh so he he ends up
leaving uh in in 1726 without earning a
degree he's got what he wanted out of it
and he decides to start studying law and
um a little bit later on in
1729 he's um G to go through a let's
call it an existential crisis you know
that's as good a name as any he
experiences a depression and this
depression turns him away from business
or pleasure
uh he decides that he really wants to
buckle down and start
studying and he devotes himself to just
months and months of this it helps him
get out of his his Funk um and uh
eventually he's going to change his his
last name to to Hume uh he's going to
try his hand as a um an apprentice to a
sugar Merchant uh that doesn't work out
particularly well Hume was never really
great in the world of business as you
know many many people uh turn out not to
be including many business people most
businesses fail it it was the case back
then just as it is now and he decides
that he he wants to start
writing and so the first thing that he's
going to work on the first main work is
this the treaties of human nature and
you can tell I mean looking at it it's a
big book right it's divided into three
parts Parts the first part is about our
ideas where we get them from this is
what we call epistemology in in
philosophy right there's a bit of
metaphysics involved there as well the
second whole part of it is is on the
passions um what we typically nowadays
call emotions how do they work so it's
psychology right and then the third part
is social theory it's about the virtues
and Justice how do they actually work
he's he's developing an Ethics that he's
putting forward and it is
entirely
unsuccessful um he makes very little
impact he gets a quite discouraged by
this but he does bounce back um and and
we'll talk about about that in just a
bit um and then so here's here's a you
know contemporary version of the thing
that will actually get him a lot of
attention essays moral political and
literary and you know big thick book as
well he's been writing essays on a
variety of topics um this is actually a
special version that has the essays that
were uh unpublished or as we say
withdrawn right they were going to go to
the publisher and then somebody was
going to raise a stink about it and he's
like maybe I better not publish this but
he's got a lot of other ones in here
ranging over a ton of topics some are
political some are aesthetic some are
about different philosophers and why
they get things wrong some are about
matters of religion
and so you know once he publishes that
that sort of puts him on the map and he
tries to become a university Professor
uh actually two times first at Edinburg
and then at
Glasgow and at Edinburg he runs into a a
real snag um there's a lot of people who
are you know looking forward to him
being a a good candidate but um he has a
reputation at the time perhaps
deserved for being an
atheist and that was enough to get
you not kicked out of a job that's the
wrong way because he never got into the
job uh that was enough to get you
excluded from being considered there was
actually a local preacher who you know
went to some of the decision makers he's
like you better not let this person into
the university similar problem happened
with Glasgow he had this reputation in
part from his his essays for not being
you know not only not being an Orthodox
Christian but actually being at the
Other Extreme being being an atheist um
which he probably was you know if you
look at his his writings on religion he
he usually played these things kind of
close to the chest as as we say so he
doesn't get that um he uh he works as a
tutor um publishes some other things and
then he so he's not good in business but
he is good in political Affairs he hooks
up with this guy um General St James
stclair and they go on an expedition to
Britney which is you know in in northern
France and it's a military Expedition
doesn't accomplish anything the way most
typically you know turn out uh but he
has a great time along the way and learn
something about you know military life
and then he accompanies St Clair as a
part of an embassy to uh Vienna and to
Turan so now he's getting to travel
around and the best way to travel
somebody else's dime right um so he's
he's he's doing that sort of thing he
doesn't have an expense account of
course but he's uh getting to travel in
somebody's Entourage and then he comes
back to
Scotland and moves to Edinburg lives
with his sister Catherine and he takes
this book uh treaties on human nature
and he's like I wonder if I can do
something with this and what he ends up
doing is taking the first book of it the
first part of it and turning that into
something called the inquiry concerning
human understanding so he repurposes his
content if we want to talk in Internet
terms right and then later on he's going
to do the same thing with book three uh
he's going to repurpose that as his
favorite of his his Works um the inquiry
concerning the principles of morals and
that's in
1751 he begins writing what I actually
think is one of his most brilliant works
the dialogues concerning natural
religion this is one that we often have
undergraduates reading like an intro to
philosophy classes but he doesn't
publish it it's not going to get
published until he's
dead um because it's arguing against a
lot of the ideas and arguments that
traditional religious people have at the
time and we so we'll talk about that in
a bit he does get some recognition uh
like I put in here he's elected
Secretary of the the philosophy Society
that's kind of a good honor um he's also
elected as Keeper Of The Advocates
library now Advocates are lawyers so you
know he's he's straying over into other
fields philosophy law politics economics
they weren't all totally separate
departments at that time you know Hume
is kind of um he's not living in the
Renaissance but he's kind of a
renaissance man in that respect he'll
he'll resign as the keeper because
there's a little tiff over expelled
books now you might say well how the
hell do you expel a book well you you
get rid of it right uh it's instead of
an expelled student the books are to
blame get rid of those and he you know
he doesn't like that idea so he he
resigns um he will also
um be one of the
founders of of uh the uh where do I have
this uh the select Society of Edinburg
so the select Society I guess you know
reading about it it's sort of like um
I'm I'm blanking on the name it's for
public speaking Toast Masters right
learning how to speak well learning how
to debate all all that sort of stuff so
Hume is one of the founding members and
within a year they've got 80 different
members and they're all you know arguing
with each other about different things
and having a great time doing it and
it's founded to make you a better uh
arguer a better orator a better debater
um and then he begins publishing in
1754 his something that's going to make
him a lot of money and give him the
reputation that he has in the 18th
century his history of England and now
if you notice the dates and the numbers
it's not published in the order that we
would expect volume Five what's going to
become volume Five gets published first
and then volume six and then he goes
back to the the other ones and these are
incredibly popular they sell quite well
um some people are like this is bad
history but Hume is doing something a
bit new with with the work that he's
he's doing so this just cements his
reputation uh 1763 he gets to go to
Paris and and Paris was the place to be
besides Edinburg at the time you know
intellectual Center he gets invited to
the salons um he gets to um you know
chat with the ladies and flirt and stuff
like that never really gets involved
with any of them but he has again he has
a great time him was known as kind of a
bone viant as you know the kind of
person you you'd want at a party and in
France he meets a guy who we've actually
done a session on who is a brilliant but
a real jerk and like a jerk not just in
one way but like kind of across the
Spectrum Jean jaac
rouso and rouso is a very important uh
philosopher from hume's time he's he's I
mean you could say he's French he writes
in French he's actually Swiss um but
ruso he really has a a knack for ticking
people people off and he he was kind of
a a jerk in his personal life too I mean
he didn't take care of any of his kids
um he had you know weird predels he had
all sorts of ideas that he'd write down
and he got in trouble with the French
with the French uh political
establishment they they actually put
arrest warrant out for him and so he is
going to bring rouso to England and Hume
is really nice guy you know so for rouso
to get to the point where hum is like
all right buddy you got got to get the
hell out of here I can't even put up
with you rouso was pretty pretty bad he
was not a good guest and then he and
Hume both published things about why
their very public friendship broke up um
you know Russo is telling his side Hume
is telling his side um and then you know
after that Hume is appointed um under
secretary for of State for the northern
department so he gets a government job
and according to him at that time
this like gave him a an inside look into
how government was actually working in
the United Kingdom and you know how was
it working not particularly
well so you know the sort of things that
you see if you actually do participate
not just in local government where all
sorts of petty personal conflicts can
can happen but in national government
right um and this is you know towards
getting towards the end of his life um
he returns to Edinburg in
1769 1772 he starts to have health
problems he uh by the by middle age he
was seriously
overweight um back then their diets
weren't great it was common to have gout
and and things like that um Hume you
know is not doing doing well um he ends
up having we're not exactly sure what
happened it's called disorders in his
bowels you know something abdominal
that's not working right maybe today
they would have diagnosed him and given
him some pills or you know suggested a
regime of exercise or something but back
then there's not a lot you can do with
it and he will die uh in 1776 of
abdominal cancer um and he has to be
intered in a simple Roman tomb James
Boswell who he'd fallen out with who's
another major writer of the time
actually a student of Adam Smith who hum
Ben friends with
um is there in attendance and and writes
about that and then you notice after he
dies he still gets to publish things as
a matter of fact he has to publish those
after he dies because if he published
them during his lifetime it probably
would have caused trouble for him so
essays on suicide and the immortality of
the Soul um Hume he's not advocating
everybody should kill themselves but
he's considering this question is there
ever a situation in which a human being
could kill themsel and it could be
legitimate um that was supposed to go
into one of his his uh books before but
that was one of the ones where his
friends were like oh buddy if you
publish this your career is over so
maybe hold off on it the one on the
immortality of the Soul Hume doesn't
think that the soul is Immortal there's
no good Arguments for it so again you
know if you say something like that in a
country where people have just been
fight fighting each other over which
interpretation of Christianity is the
right one you're probably going to get
yourself in some trouble and then
finally dialogues concerning natural
religion published in
1779 and that that sort of completes not
just his life but you could say his
legacy within and close to his his
lifetime uh so you know it's kind of a
great loss you notice that he's able to
see the uh American Revolution happening
Hume actually thought the uh
revolutionists had a good beef with the
home country and he suggested making
peace with them um he's going to be
influential on some of the people we
call founding fathers because he's an
important you know British thinker at
the time um James Madison uh is
influenced by him Thomas Jefferson is
influenced the other way thinks Hume is
a terrible guy don't be like Hume but he
also had a friend friendship with
Benjamin Franklin you know
he he hosted him at at one time so he's
got a lot of interesting
connections um so let's take a little
pause here before we go into like well
what was what were what were his ideas
what what was the stuff he actually
wrote about any uh things you want to
ask about or
clarifications at this
time yeah out of curiosity if he was at
Edinburgh at the age of 12 yeah in what
languages was he studying like very many
people did knew Greek and Latin at that
time a 12-year-old do that oh yeah I
mean it depends on the kind of family
you come from right so like this is a
couple Generations later John Stewart
Mill when he is just a I mean he wasn't
a toddler um he would have been a young
child he learns Greek and Latin well
enough to actually tutor his younger
siblings in it so I mean you start out a
kid who's smart early enough and give
them the right kind of like
encouragement and and you know they can
they can learn quite a bit and yeah
those are you know it's an interesting
thing that Greek useful not as useful as
it will become later on Latin was still
sort of the linga franka for learned
life in Europe in the um the 18th
century um in ways that we you know we
often oh it was a dead language no no
they they weren't using it for
day-to-day life obviously right but um a
lot of Works were written in in Latin um
now this is an earlier Century decart's
meditations not written in French
written in Latin by Renee deart and then
he had somebody else even though he
spoke French translated into French you
know um he again earlier Century de cart
writes the discourse on method in French
specifically so that women and servants
will be able to read it because the
assumption is if you're an educated
person you know Latin right so yeah
that's you know you would learn things
Hume was a smart guy you know if you
think this a total side note if you
think about the way that we do education
today for the most part we we cater to
like the kids in the middle you know um
the kids who are really smart sometimes
we have like gifted talented programs
for that but we don't want them to Jump
Ahead too far because of these
socialization concerns not an issue back
then you know if you were smart enough
to go and jump in they they'd let you do
it you know but if you screwed up then
they they'd boot you out so the proof
that you could do it was you would you
would actually do it you know any other
questions yeah
yeah
okay you said he kind of had this
falling out with his family parents
early on no no no he left them
no who are his who are the influencers
in his life Oh you mean like personal
well personal his beliefs I mean oh and
then at the end who actually sponsored I
mean who got his stuff published because
he obviously was dead oh afterwards he
before who were his influencers yeah his
life and then he died I mean we can talk
about like intellectual influences and I
I'm going to get to that in a bit um it
doesn't appear like his
family made huge Impressions on him you
know he had a decent enough um
upbringing and family life and then he
just kind of moves on I mean he's close
to his sister and his brother in the
course of his life but that's more of a
a relation of equals more than anything
else and you know his great ambition is
to be a uh famous writer so there's
plenty of other people that he can kind
of model himself after
um that he can look to and be like I
want to I want to be like that person I
want to be successful like like that
person but there there's nobody who like
takes Hume under his wing and is like
you know Hume is his Protege or
something like that but he did do stuff
like that to a limited extent with other
people like like Adam Smith is younger
than him but Smith is very much
influenced by by hum you know um Smith
is also more successful in that he's
able to become a professor you know
um but you know like
so in terms of intellectual influence
Cicero is massively important uh the
Roman writer and
orator
um you know he's he's in this um
tradition that we call empiricism so
this is actually a good jumping off
point to talk about like his his
intellectual life um we often in philos
philosophy like we're doing an intro
class or we have a textbook we say that
in the modern period there were the
British empiricists and then there were
the continental rationalists and they
disagreed about important things and
they were like parts of tradition and so
the empiricists would include um uh
early on people like Hobs and bacon and
then John Lock and and George Barkley
and and a few other people along the way
and then the Continental nationalist
Renee dickart Benedict Spinosa Nikolai
malbran uh gotri vilhelm liet and others
like that but that's kind of a distorted
picture because the empiricists so
they're all about like let's get
experience let's find out how the world
Works let's let's pay attention to how
our ideas are put together all of it's
coming from experience they weren't
really all like that Lo has got
rationalist ideas they they all kind of
mix and match
and the rationalists are only part of
what's going on in France and Germany
and Italy and places like that so there
were there were followers of John Lock
in France uh condoret is a a good
example of that there's a lot of
outliers who don't quite fit in there
and they're all part of this thing that
we can call the the Enlightenment and so
they're they're arguing with each other
about important things um Hume you know
Hume
is against
having too much faith in human reason
you could say so he's he's against a
kind of superficial rationalism that
says all we got to do is like think by
ourselves and we'll figure out all the
problems right hum thinks we need we
actually need to look at things in the
world but so to all the good
rationalists as
well and um one of the things that he
does that's kind of striking in in his
works but this is also typical of his
time is he often writes in the first
person right and he he'll say you know I
scrutinize my own thoughts and feelings
and here's what I actually find maybe
you find other stuff but here's what
I've got so that's what's going into my
book or my essays if you find something
else you let me know you know um I can
only go by what it is that that I myself
actually know but this is again
something that all sorts of other
authors are doing and I guess the other
that's important to keep in mind about
him going to this issue of
influence is he he doesn't belong to a
school you know um in the sense of like
belonging to a
tradition that you you're like well
these are the things we have to believe
if we're going to be a cartisian
follower of Renee diart or we're GNA be
a um spinosi which would get you in
trouble by the way being a spinosi back
then um he's a
skeptic and and Cicero who I mentioned
was a big influence Cicero was also a
skeptic but they're not Skeptics of the
sort um the the extreme ones who are
like ah we can't know anything nobody
can know anything hum's more like uh
well there's a lot of different ways of
looking at things how do we know which
one is actually correct let's do our
best try to figure it out uh we'll play
the arguments off against each other we
might not be able to arrive at a
definite conclusion that we know to be
the case but let's you know let's do our
best with it and once we get as far as
we can take these things that's that's
as far as we're going to go that's
that's all that we actually get and
that's what you find in his his treaties
and that's what you find in his his
other works
um so you know he doesn't he doesn't
belong to a school as such he has
massive effects on other people but I
guess you could say that he's he's more
influenced by what he
judiciously accepts bit by bit from
people rather than like taking out an
entire program from somebody and saying
I'm gonna be like like this person so in
a way he kind of cobbles together a a
whole philosophy you know rather than um
taking it from some somebody else which
is kind of a cool thing to do I hadn't
really thought of him that way but yeah
um a few key ideas about his his Works
um why was he so important right um so
sometimes we can line these up with
famous quips or quotes which you know as
those things tend to be are a little bit
misleading so one of them that you might
have heard of tell me if you have reason
is and ought only to be the slave of the
passions is that is that a familiar line
to any of you um Hume said it he said it
in this first book The the treaties
right he doesn't mean it like in the
sense that well you can't ever think
about anything and you just ought to
feel right um because you know he's he's
actually using reason to figure out how
we work how the human mind ticks how the
emotions work and how we should guide
them but what he's really suspicious of
are people who have all the answers
figured out in advance and you know when
you ask them well what's your basis for
that they're they're like reason I just
thought it out I figured it out myself
hum is like that's not gonna work just
as much as like any of you ever been on
like a diet or an exercise program
you're going to try try to change your
your physical health um maybe you had to
give give up smoking or something like
that um how do you motivate yourself you
can't just like say well I know this is
the right thing for me to do everything
falls into place right I mean you can
try that feel free but it doesn't work
because you need some sort of emotional
motivation some passional motivation for
that right so why do you you know like
why do I
exercise in part because I don't want to
uh get any fatter than I am right now
and I'm getting older and I do want to
make sure that my bones don't get
brittle and I would like to you know my
kids are too old too old and too big now
to like ride on my shoulders or stuff
like that that used to be something I'd
be like so I can carry my kids around
but I'd like to if we you know have
something going on at home I'd like to
be able to pick up heavy boxes and move
them from place to place to not be
dependent right um those are
emotional
reasons that aren't directly tied to you
know pure
logical Spock like you know reason that
has no emotions involved that that's
part of what Hume is is saying um if we
want to think about how we ought to live
our life we need to think about what do
we actually feel and whether we're
feeling the right things um in ethics he
is an advocate of what we call moral
sentimentalism which means that we do
take our feelings into consideration and
one of the most important feelings is
what he calls sympathy um and by this
you know you sometimes people get really
precious and Technical about well
there's empathy there's there's
compassion there's sympathy there's you
know all all these things they're not
the same thing well they are the same
thing for hum right because nobody is
making those distinctions back then the
term sympathy means being able to feel
what other people are feeling or imagine
ourselves in their place and feel bad
when you see somebody walking along and
tripping and smacking their face on the
floor or you know losing the purse of
coins that they have or getting beaten
up you know and then can motivate you to
do the right thing and he thinks that
ethics really ought to be based in large
part on this feeling of sympathy for
other other humans and maybe even
animals to to some degree um he doesn't
like people who are very as he puts it
enthusiastic meaning that they take a
very hard position on things and are
willing to like go to war over it you
know over matters of religion or
politics he likes people who kind of
middle of the road you know who can get
along with other people he doesn't like
factionalism um he also so those are you
know sort of things having to do with
ethics interestingly he will claim and
this goes back to that first person
perspective thing he says when I look
inside of myself I don't find anything
that I can call my self something that
is permanent something that is the core
of who I am all I find are a bunch of
different things bunch of memories bunch
of Impressions a bunch of habits all of
these things connected together and
that's me that's that's the David Hume I
know myself as but there's no like
little core no substance that I can find
inside of myself and I don't think this
is him I don't think any of the rest of
you can do that either if you can show
it to me now obviously you can't show
that to to anybody else right and so
this is a really important uh position
that he he's taking and a lot of people
in philosophy and even in you know
ordinary life they look at him and
they're like yeah maybe we don't
actually have a self there was some
conjecture about did he get this from
like
Western uh interpretations of Buddhism
which were starting to trickle into
Europe at the time the answer is we
don't know probably not he seems to have
come up with this independently um there
were some Scholars who are writing about
that we have no evidence that Hume
actually read any of them so we we don't
we don't know one way or the other yeah
he talks about so call yeah did he spell
out what that cor was he thinks there
isn't one excuse me he thinks there
isn't one so he can't spell it
out well he's searching for a core he
must have an idea
no he says there's nothing that I can
find that corresponds to like a a
lasting
permanent and I'm using the word core he
doesn't use the word core I'm just I'm
just paraphrasing he's saying you know
people talk about like having a soul or
you know Renee dayart talks about his
mind being what he is I don't find that
in me you know all I find when I look
within are like what I ate for dinner
and you know what I'm thinking about
doing next and you know some memories
from when I was a kid and I don't I
don't find any single thing that is a
Unity believe what's that could his
belief have
any U impact on that reasoning because
the had the belief he was he says dart's
wrong excuse me he's saying dart's wrong
that deart misled himself you know um
and this is where you like maybe dart's
right and Hume is wrong you know um but
he thinks that that everybody's fooling
themselves if they think there is a
permanent locus of identity that we we
have um and this is you know this is
where like when you look at philosophers
sometimes you got to go this way or you
got to go that way you know so
um yeah I mean I I tend to think that
some of these things some of these
problems like he also talks about free
will too do we have free will or do we
not have free will you always get ask
well what do they mean by this term
right does it mean that we like with
free will do we make choices obviously
we do right do we waver between
Alternatives sure um can there be
factors that influence us yeah um but
there's also like a little wiggle room
that we have if you want to call Free
Will that then hume's like sure then you
got free will but if you mean like this
capacity to choose in every circumstance
what you want to do without being
influenced by other things or throwing
that influence aside then you know not
even people who who advocate for free
will believe in that you know so yeah um
when you say he didn't have a
core no he doesn't think that we have
have a yeah how I'm trying to reconcile
that with the fact that yet he wrote
essays on morality sure yeah you could
you could not have a lasting permanent
core that is the Crux of who you are and
then all the other stuff is just like
extra uh and and have moral sentiments
and ideas about right and wrong I mean
you don't you don't have to be the same
person that you were when you were six
and you can still have moral beliefs you
know always kind of associated here your
moral beliefs with something core oh
well we're using core in two different
ways then right core the way you're
using it means important to you right
I'm talking about having something like
a soul that would remain the same no
matter what across the course of your
life and perhaps Beyond it Hume doesn't
think we have that but you could you
could be as he calls it a bundle of
Sensations and memories and Impressions
and some of those could be about moral
life like you could have the impression
somebody did me the wrong thing
yesterday well you might change that
later on you might you know come to say
oh I was wrong about that but that
doesn't mean that you don't have beliefs
about morality you know see I I think
morality um evolves from what is core in
the sense you again you're using core in
a different way than than Hume is so
yeah you mean about things that are
important to us well that whatever your
your beliefs your morals yeah um it's
not it's not a function of importance
but they rise up out of some of them do
some of them don't I mean as as as
children we learn all sorts of moral
lessons that we don't actually like and
we're just kind of stuck with that's
part of our moral development right
that's not core to us but it be it can
become core in the sense of being
important because we're like well I
better behave or I'm going to get
punished and I don't like that so I need
to learn what counts as being a good
person in this Society um it doesn't
arise spontaneously out of some you you
know Wonderful Center of ourselves um
children typically are kind of jerks you
know and and need to be civilized um but
hum thinks that hum you know older
people are like that too that you know
there is no one single thing that I can
call myself I am a whole bunch of things
you know and no one single one of them
is the thing that I am but you can still
have moral ideas and behave morally even
if that's the the case
um it gets it gets weirder yet um the
biggest thing that he's known for and
that's one of the handouts that I I gave
you Hume says that um our notion of
cause and effect which is absolutely
necessary for having science metaphysics
these sorts of
things it's not
real it doesn't mean that things don't
happen but there is no such thing as
like causality where you know this thing
makes this thing happen over here all we
actually observe when we're paying
attention is constant conjunction this
thing happens this thing happens we
associate them together why do we do
that Association of ideas it's part of
our psychology we develop something that
that he calls custom which is like a a
sort of big habit and so then we were
like yeah I mean the fire uh I see the
fire I see the smoke the the smoke the
fire is causing the smoke no all we
actually observe are the two things and
it's it's the same with like internal
Sensations I have ath thought you know
that thought should lead to this thought
well it's just because we've connected
them up in this way that's part of what
our culture has done now if you buy into
this you might say well holy crap then I
can't trust anything he says no no no
don't worry about that because we do
have all these regular patterns that
that happen right it's just that they're
not
100% you know um you can't be 100% a
priori you know clear about anything in
advance when it comes to cause and
effect you can just say well you know
these are the ways things typically
happen the way that we actually do treat
things in in real life you know think
about medicine um if you ever get
surgery one of the things they have you
sign uh says that I understand that
medicine is not an exact
science that things could go crazy that
you know maybe this thing uh is is going
to be you know what the doctor does but
it could lead to very different effects
it probably won't but it could you never
know right and um Hume thinks that
that's that's what our whole notion of
like power cause and effect um you know
all all the things that we we use I me
think about our technology that relies
on uh hard Notions that this thing will
happen if this thing happens yeah our
technology fails all the time in weird
unpredictable ways you know we're lucky
we have the regularity in life that we
actually do you know um we don't need to
have it be 100% in order to live you
know and he he talks about like you know
you can sit in your study and think
these thoughts and realize as a
philosopher that you know these are a
little
troubling but then you know go out with
your friends and he would say play
Billiards shoot pool right and you don't
suddenly worry about whether you you hit
the ball it's GNA like you know float
off into the the sky or something you
think it's GNA go and hit that thing
what's your basis for that you've
observed that sort of thing happening
all all sorts of times before now things
that we don't know anything about we can
make up all sorts of imaginary scenarios
about them but we don't really know how
they'll how they'll work until we try
him out you know so you know again this
is not something you necessarily need to
believe but this is what Hume thought
and this winds up being what a lot of
other people buy into uh from him now
weirdly and in contradiction to that he
tells us that what we can count on is
human nature being the same across every
culture not only in his time but he says
actually going back to like the greek
latin thing right he says you know if we
want to know about what ancient Romans
and Greeks were like we just need to
look at English people and and French
people of our own time because they're
basically all the same and then he you
know this doesn't this isn't something
he could actually have good basis for
saying and it's contradicted by another
essay that he has which is called on
National characters where he's saying
you know French you know the how
comedians will be like these people are
like this these people are are like this
um so he's saying you know French people
are like this typically not all of them
but a lot of them English people are
more like this like the English are the
most courageous and he attributes that
weirdly to being carnivorous you know
now so so sometimes you you see stuff
that Hume says and you're
like you know he should have known that
this is a garbage argument you know even
himself why is he putting this out there
and you know not everybody hits uh 100
or what is it bats a thousand um among
all the philosophers but you know he's
he's uh got some interesting ideas one
of the things that he does say though is
that he uh you know we often say what is
the human being how do we Define it um
we're an animal but what kind a rational
animal right so that's how we're
fundamentally different from what he
calls the brutes meaning all the other
stupid animals hum doesn't buy that he
actually says you know dogs
donkeys they actually reason just not as
well as we do and they don't use the
kind of language that we do but you can
watch an animal and you can see it doing
problem solving now some are stupid you
know even among smart animals so you
know think about the ones that we think
are like super smart you know like crows
and and elephants and apes and uh
cations like whales and dolphins there's
bound to be a few dummies in there you
know mixed into them right but for the
most part you can you can wa even your
cat like you can watch your cat trying
to figure out how to open the door um
that means that animals reason not as
well as us but you know we're not
radically different from them um I'm
going to skip ahead a little bit just I
want to be uh aware of time I mentioned
that he talks you know about religious
topics so Hume thought and he's actually
got a piece about miracles that he by
the way he left out of the treaties he
called it castrating his own work um and
the reason he did it is because he knew
he'd get in trouble and he'd get in
trouble with a guy who was particularly
important in British intellectual life
at the T the time uh Bishop Butler and
so Hume you know it didn't do any good
Bishop Butler and others weren't
interested in this work anyway but um
later on in the the inquiry concerning
human understanding he will make a
really interesting discussion of
Miracles and part of his argument is you
know it's not as if Miracles couldn't
happen we just don't have any good
reason to think they ever do because all
of the reasons for that would be based
on
testimony and testimony about things
going weird going unusually astray has
to be really really good
testimony and where are we going to get
that we don't know these people like you
know think about the the gospel writers
the apostles you know or their
secretaries like like you know Mark uh
secretary to Peter writing stuff down
he's like that was you know centuries
ago none of us know these people why
would we automatically believe that
they're not mixed up or tell you know
they're actually telling the truth and
you know boy if that had been published
back then he wouldn't have ever gotten
anybody to listen to him and he he got
in quite a bit of trouble even having it
published within his lifetime um the
dialogues concerning natural religion go
even further and here so I mentioned we
were talking about Cicero before right
Cicero who Hume really really likes has
a book called on the nature of the Gods
and Cicero is writing back in in ancient
Roman times right he's he's prior to
Christianity coming on the scene he is
actually there at the breakup of the
Roman Republic and the transformation
into an empire under Julius Caesar who
Cicero fought against in a in a civil
war and Cicero has uh an epicurian
philosopher a stoic philosopher and a
skeptic philosopher who happens to be a
priest in the Roman religion but doesn't
believe in any of this
stuff presenting their points of view
and Cicero doesn't endorse any of them
but he lets them fight with each other
Hume does the same thing in the
dialogues concerning natural religion he
has three different
Christians and each of them proves how
the other Christian has things wrong and
when you do that the sum total is
they're all wrong none of them have the
right conception of God none of them can
prove anything that they assert and so
it's very subversive it's it's a very
interesting strategy that he's quite
deliberately
pursuing um and you know you can
understand why he had to publish it post
humously given the religious uh context
of the time because the effect of it is
to say all of these arguments trying to
prove the existence of God not a single
one of them work but you let a Christian
demolish the other Christians argument
and say oh I've got a better proof than
you and then the other guy gets to say
oh your proof sucks too you know and
then the the grand total is well they
all suck none of them work right he also
says we really can't know anything about
the nature of God uh for we you know if
we look at the world and we're like Oh
What a Wonderful World this is It's
amazing Hume says you don't know that
there's an intelligent designer it might
be a scile designer for all you know
this was the product of a God who um was
good at one point in time but then you
know he's he's not up to Snuff anymore
or it could be a whole Committee of gods
who made this world that's just as
plausible as any other narrative or it
could be something like a giant spider
spinning you know the world out of its
uh uh spinettes you know we could
imagine whatever we want and him says
any of these is just as likely as the
other one because we're off Way Beyond
the realm of our experience and what we
understand on the basis of our
experience so you know those are those
are his ideas in terms of uh religion um
I think you can kind of piece together
that Hume doesn't believe in any of this
stuff he's an atheist but he had to keep
under wraps so so those are some of his
major ideas not all of them obviously
but uh any let's take a little pause
here from for more questions and then
I'll tell you about what his effects on
History were uh which we should do his
philosophers in the midst of History so
any any questions
clarifications yeah What attracted him
in the first place to Russo oh um what
did they share in
common I mean as a turned out what do
they sh in common not a hell of a lot
you know um but it's one of those kind
of things where you think you have more
in common with somebody when you're on
good terms with them and then as you get
to know them better you realize just how
little you actually do have in in common
with them Russo is highly paranoid and
it's one of those things where you know
you know the old uh expression um just
because you're paranoid doesn't mean
they're not out to get you they were out
to get Russo right but he also he was a
drama Creator and Hume doesn't like
drama he likes things to be nice calm
easy settled rouso was one of those
people who was like continually
generating conflict and problems and I
guess Hume at first I mean he saw that
he that rouso was being
persecuted and he didn't realize that
rouso was being persecuted partly
because Russo was a jerk you know and
and brought some of this upon himself
and and so you know he invites him back
to to England to keep him safe that was
part of the motivation because there
were you know arrest warrants out for
for rouso and then rouso just acted like
such a jerk um that Hume eventually had
to be like you got to get out of here
buddy um but I mean what do they have in
common they're both they're both smart
right they are both um at least on the
surface committed to the ideals of the
Enlightenment but they have very
different interpretations of what that
looks like as as it turns out I mean you
really get to know a person well when
you live with them so
um you know hopefully all of your house
guests are better than rouso but yeah
and it you know it was funny because
once once uh their friendship broke down
rouso was a jerk in um the Republic of
letters to him too you know
so Hume actually didn't want to but he
had to publish something like presenting
his own side you know like we would do
in social media today you know yeah do
you know why he changed his name oh um
you know it wasn't it wasn't a really
big
deal changing your name yeah it was it
was like so the pronunciation as far as
I understand this the pronunciation of
Home wasn't what we say home it was
closer to to Hume right and so people
were essentially misspelling his name so
just we'll just change it because he
actually runs into another guy later on
who does have the name home um he
corresponds with him briefly um but it's
it was kind of a minor point and and you
know this is a bit off
topic orthography spelling was not
standardized in English at the time part
of what actually does contribute to that
so one one of the um things that I have
here in the timeline is um where is this
uh
um so one one of the people Boswell
publishes this dictionary of the English
language right and what does a
dictionary do I mean we think of a
dictionary as the thing you go to to
find out the definition of a word and
that's part of it a dictionary also
tells you how the word is supposed to be
spelled right and I think as educated
people who don't misspell too many words
although I you know I still misspell
words uh my students will correct me
when I'm at the chalkboard and I I get
things like the I after e except after C
wrong you know um we we're so used to it
that we tend to get words right uh a lot
of people you know will go to a
dictionary back in then that time to
find out this word that I know orally
how the hell is it spelled you know um
by the way English is a bad language for
that right because our spelling stuff
doesn't make a lot of sense French is
just as bad you know um there was a
survey that I read back when I was in my
20s and it was in a magazine called Lear
which is this French literary magazine
and they pulled their literate readers
so they're not pulling the average
person on the street they're they're
pulling people who read literature and
they were like question number one does
French spelling make any sense and 75%
of the people said nope not at all right
and then 25% were like yeah it's it's
just fine and then they asked a
follow-up question would you like to see
the French language changed so that the
spelling makes sense 75% of the people
said nope don't change a damn thing and
then 25% of the people were like yeah we
probably need to sort this out you know
I think if you were going to do that
with English uh language maybe the
numbers would be a little bit different
but but people tend to be pretty
conservative you know when it comes to
messing with their their language they
don't like people to change it you know
so long long digression off of the
changing of the the name any other
questions or yeah yeah I'm just trying
to understand like the habit and custom
thing is that really all that different
from cause and
effect well different in in in some ways
um it's saying there is no such thing as
as real cause and effect it's just us
putting it together right now if your
understanding of cause and effect is
well it's just a habit then no but
that's not what most people tend to mean
by causality they want it to mean
something like in the nature of the
world you know okay but he doesn't he
doesn't believe in miracles or he just
doesn't think that there's a good
justification he says evidence for that
yeah says uh I mean a miracle could
happen it would be a violation of the
laws of
nature um but why would we ever believe
any account of a miracle given by
somebody you know even if it happened to
us we'd probably like look for as we say
IR rational explanation right or a
scientific explanation and then maybe we
don't have it but if I tell you my story
about the miracle that happened to me
you you know you have to ask well do I
trust this guy you know does he have any
agenda is he trying to like sell me
something and him says we just don't
have any good reason to think that
anybody who does report a miracle
actually witnessed a miracle you
know so yeah but you know once we take
like let's call it strict cause and
effect like metaphysical cause and
effect once you take that out of the
picture and you say well it's just this
Loosey Goosey custom thing that people
have I mean we could have all sorts
of unexpected things happen that we
could call Miracles right it's just that
why would we why would we accept the
testimony of anybody about them and Hume
says in most cases we wouldn't you know
I mean there could be a case where
there's some like absolutely
incontrovertible thing that we all see
happen and we're like holy crap it's a
miracle and then Hume says great show me
one of those and there aren't any you
know at this point in time but he he
doesn't rule it out a priori he just
says we just don't get that sort of
thing did you have your hand up I had a
question who influenced his works either
among his contemporary whether it is on
of Europe or prior to his time yeah so
Cicero as we mentioned massive influence
on him uh he is within the empiricist
current so he's read John Lock he's read
Thomas Hobbs he's you know Bishop Butler
who I mentioned is somebody who uh Hume
influences and is also influenced by
Hume
the influence on Adam Smith goes both
ways you know um he's also you know he's
also engaged with um figures outside of
uh Great Britain um so you know he's
part you could say he's part of an
intellectual millu so it's less this one
single person in it influenced him and
more like you know so take take the
notion of Freedom or Liberty right hum
thinks that's really important and part
of his history is that human beings are
moving towards more and more Liberty in
in baby steps here and there there's a
whole bunch of people saying similar
things um there's no one single one who
hum is like I got this idea from this
guy and that's what I'm gonna run with
um there's a lot of ideas that are you
could say in the air you know
um I mean in some respects part of what
we like about him is that he's not
emerging from a pure vacuum but he is a
he is an original thinker you know um
sort of like Thomas Hobbs or Renee
dekart um they they definitely have
people who influence them but for the
most part they're kind of doing their
own thing with it even even Cicero hum
is like reinterpreting what what Cicero
is doing to suit his own projects and
ends you
know well let's talk about hum's
influence then so in his own time like I
mentioned not that important as a
philosopher more important as a literary
figure and as a historian and his
history gets um praised and criticized
by lots of different people um some
pretty extreme positions on that Thomas
Jefferson says that his WR his writings
are poison and it would spread
universalism meaning like conservativism
throughout the land you know um but
Samuel Johnson you know liked Hume quite
a bit um he actually says that that Hume
doesn't have any principles he's he's a
hobbist meaning a follower of Thomas
Hobs um Hume himself said I'm not a wig
oratory those are the big parties at the
time uh he said that uh My Views are
more conformable to wig principles my
representations of persons to Tory
prejudices so he's kind of finding a
middle ground not identifying with
either party
and in his own time his uh political and
economic ideas are are pretty important
but we don't really read him for that
too much anymore um you could say by the
mid 19th century that that part of it is
is gone but his philosophical importance
he is considered like you know when they
do these polls of professional
philosophers who is the most important
philosophical writer David hum is always
in the top 10
because he contributed so massively
perhaps wrongly but but massively to
metaphysics epistemology ethics
Aesthetics all of these these sorts of
things um oh philosophy of religion too
I mean people still use his arguments in
the philosophy of religion in atheist
versus Christian debates on the internet
he's he's widely um read Emanuel Kant
who we're going to look at next year um
he credits Hume for as he says Awakening
me from my dogmatic Slumber so dogmatic
meaning like committed to a particular
set of ideas and just kind of like going
through life now Kant was a university
professor and he'd written books right
and he's like wow when I read David Hume
I was like there are some problems that
I hadn't even thought of and I better
take care of these and so that Spurs him
to do his massive work afterwards as an
older philosopher writing three
critiques critique of pure reason
critique of practical reason critique of
judgment uh a whole bunch of other works
as well uh including some works in the
philosophy of religion so you know no K
or no Hume probably no K and Kant is
massively important within the 19th and
20th centuries um Arthur schopenhauer
who was a conscient of sorts actually
thought that he was like the only true
follower of K
schopenhauer is a pretty polarizing
figure he takes hume's ethics of
sympathy and incorporates that into his
own ethics uh says that Hume is the
person who's got all this stuff right um
Adam Smith you know who we know from his
his you know very important uh work
justifying a certain kind of capitalism
not the capitalism that we know today
Smith would be like turning over in his
grave but a Wealth of Nations um that's
influenced by hum's economic rights ings
I mean they were friends they chatted
about these things uh Smith had another
book that was just as important a theory
of moral sentiments that's in line with
hume's thought as well um Edmund Hol one
of the founders of
phenomenology uses hume's notion of
Association of ideas incorporates that
into his philosophy AJ a who writes this
very important book language truth and
logic one of the early logical
positivists he is essentially a humi and
you can say that anglo-american analytic
Philosophy for many decades is very much
inspired by David hume's thought not
only in terms of metaphysics and ethics
but in terms of eth metaphysics and and
epistemology but also ethics and
Aesthetics so he winds up having a
massive effect this is part of why he's
considered to be such an important
philosopher um and I'll mention one
person you probably haven't heard of who
I'm a big big fan of this guy L shesto
he was a um Russian Jewish philosopher
who left after the revolution came to
Paris um wrote a lot of interesting very
unsystematic Works probably the most
famous of which is called Athens and
Jerusalem um unfortunately didn't have
that much influence because his only
major student Benjamin fonden died in
the uh concentration camps because he
also was was Jewish um but chest is a
really interesting thinker and he takes
hume's
ideas and kind of goes further with them
like the causality thing he's like yeah
hume's right we don't know anything
about real cause and effect and we never
will doesn't mean we can't live our
lives but you know we we don't have to
buy into all this crazy philosophy stuff
that the philosophers are always trying
to push on us Hume gives us away out of
that he takes other interesting ideas
from Hume pushing that skepticism
further and you know I'm I'm going to be
teaching Hume to my Marquette
undergraduates in how many weeks we're
doing decart this week and next week so
in in two more weeks I'm teaching David
Hume we're we're not looking at this
book because it's too long but his
inquiry concerning human understanding
um why are we teaching him because he's
an important thinker and he's got really
interesting ideas like the does cause
and effect really hold or is human
nature the same everywhere or can
animals think a big question for us in
the present when some people are like
animals aren't even sensient you know
you hear things like that and you're
like man have you ever had a pet you
know you ever spent any time with
animals uh but there are philosophers
who want to deny that animals have any
Consciousness Hume is somebody relevant
to that so he's really quite a um
interesting guy to to uh to work through
so th those are all the remarks that I
have um I'm certainly happy to entertain
any any more questions could be
historical could be philosophical could
be uh seemingly trivial because they're
probably not uh what else what else do
you have for me yeah um I I hit a
roadblock here when you talked about uh
cause and effect yeah and then natural
law oh so so so Hume doesn't think there
are natural laws do not believe in
natural law not so there there's two
different understandings of natural law
okay one is an ethical one yeah where we
have like certain
impulses implanted in Us by Nature by
the kind of creatures that we are and
then we reason about that and humans not
part of that tradition of uh it's going
to turn off of the natural law thing
that goes back to the stoics and then
goes through the medievals and then
there's natural law in the sense of like
physical law right so I'm thinking more
in terms of the physical yeah and and I
get the point that say okay if I if I
drop my pen the floor M okay that's an
observation yeah yeah and you could
argue that well I mean and every time
you do it it's G to hit the floor hitor
at what point do you say you've done
enough observations to say hey yeah
that's going to hold all the time yeah
so Hume says you have done enough to
have the belief the conviction the the
custom The Habit to expect that it's
going to do that but you never do
know you never know like with a like
totally a priori the universe must be
this way he says you just never get that
because how would you get that from
experience right now this is where where
Kant actually says it's it's uh Hume
actually was on the right track but he
didn't go deep enough I'm gonna go
deeper and I'm going to say that um
cause and effect isn't out there in
things it's in the way our minds project
order onto the universe that we
experience we can't not see things that
way and he thinks that this is different
than Hume just saying ah it's it's
Association of ideas you know um but
maybe it isn't well you yeah you get you
get the point of saying yeah yeah in in
a different Universe yes things would be
different and you know this comes
through with yeah yeah with Einstein
saying that you know in you can't you
can never get to the speed of light
however
in in in an alternate a different type
of universe which we if if it had
different ways of things yeah yeah yeah
or like what if gravity operated
according to an inverse Cube law instead
of an inverse uh Square law I mean if it
did we'd be screwed you know but U but
different things would happen yeah um
hum just thinks that we human beings we
can't you know we can imagine that all
we want right we can do thought
experiments but um we can never
accumulate enough observations
experiments experiences to actually say
what the hell is actually going on we
can get deeper and deeper and deeper
right with our then that that that kind
of intersects with the thought of a
miracle yeah I Dro my pen 99 times 100
times and 99 times it hits the floor
yeah but that one out of n out of 100 it
doesn't that might be a miracle it might
be but what hum would do he'd be like
okay so what's different in this
situation was it like a puff of air that
held it up is there a string he he'
start looking for the most likely
explanations rather than being like
obviously God made it
happen um now you know there's there's
certain things where you could be like
but isn't that exactly the sort of thing
you'd expect God to do right um if you
think about like the classical biblical
Miracles and we'll just take the ones
that that um in the the New Testament
Jesus performs according to all the the
gospel stories right so like you know
the it's interesting too because the way
that they're they're like set up
narratively um think about the water to
wine thing at canaa right you don't get
um Jesus saying first his mom wants him
to to fix things right she doesn't say
do a miracle she just says hey they're
out of wine do something you know and
he's like ah it's not my time you know
and then she's like I'm your mom you're
going to do it right now he doesn't like
say okay please bring up these jars of
water everybody look inside do you see
that it's it's it's water oh hey Presto
boom it's wine he just says Hey do you
look over there you know um and they're
like well that that's water over there
and he's like better check again you
know I mean I'm roughly paraphrasing
right and maybe in a factious way but
you know if something like that happened
you could be like well maybe I did
misplace the wine maybe somebody carded
it in those are other possible explan
the most intriguing along those lines to
me is the causing the blind man to see
oh yeah the Blind Man's been blind from
birth so how did he yeah yeah that's a
good one be able to understand well
bread is
red this is this is dirt this is you
know because these are all things that
are on us as we grow that's that's an
interesting one that's something that
Hume actually not that Miracle but the
idea of a blind person having uh sight
restored to him Hume actually
thinks that they wouldn't be able to
make sense of that information and I I
think we probably would
say at least at first they're not going
to know what the hell they're looking at
right maybe over time as they have
experiences they can start to grasp
color just like deaf people who um have
hearing restored hearing impaired or de
people yes yeah yeah yeah I mean now
understood as a miracle yeah I mean in
in in the story what does he do he's
like I think if I remember right he like
rubs spittle on on the guy's eyee and um
so you could be like well every time I
do that it doesn't cure a blind guy
right I a lot of blind guys let me go up
to them and spit in my fingers and rub
it on them um it must be it must be a
miracle Hume would be like well maybe
there's some medicinal properties in the
spittle but but the other part like you
mentioned he actually processes visual
information yeah I think hum would have
a hard time explaining that one yeah
right um but it' also say how do you
know that actually happened you know um
would the apostles have had any reason
to like embellish stories we don't know
you know that's basically his point
there yeah any yeah um do you think I
kind of never studied this subject but
um I'm struck by the fact that he's a
top within the top 10 W um do you think
his value was most as a philosop phos
opher oh or as a pro
provocateur um the thought of others
philosoph oh so so like other philosoph
you yeah so let me rephrase it is his
value in his own philosophical ideas
like understood as being the right way
to look at things and systematically
interpreting the world or as a disruptor
a disruptor somebody who like you said
provokes others to to go beond him or to
think different yeah that's a great
question
um I think I mean personally because I
actually think hum is wrong um I I don't
think that he he got like the whole
system of how things are correct I think
there's some some serious problems some
contradictions in in his work I'm not
going to say that his point of view
is valuable primarily because he got
things right because I think he's wrong
so I I would say personally that like
you know if you can get a a Manuel K to
take you seriously and say I'm gonna
write books in response to this guy
that's pretty important right or there
and there's plenty of other people who
are like this Hume guy he's awful you
know well you you got to write a book
kind of provoking them to think yeah
their line of
thinking yeah you don't have to put a
value judgment on what he say he a
disrupt yeah I will say this though um
there's some there's something about the
way that he puts his thoughts together
that even though I don't accept them I
find them attractive and I and I I do
this as well with Emanuel and with
Renee diart and with um you know other
philosophers um that's probably why I'm
still in the philosophy business you
know because otherwi you get people in
the philosophy business who are like I
want the one true philosophy and if I
can't have that it's all crap or or
they're like I've found it it's this guy
here or this this woman here and I'm
just going to be like preaching their
gospel the rest of my career I'm a
different kind of person I like and I
think humo is in a certain way too he
could appreciate Cicero without thinking
Cicero was correct um and learn from him
so I I like reading and teaching these
people even though I think that they've
got some stuff wrong and maybe part of
it is because of the Prov the
provocative idea like well what if
animals really do think how do we how do
we treat them then I mean factory
farming uh which is already pretty
horrific even if they're just meat
machines really has to go out the window
if if you know maybe it was the value in
the questions he asked that's part of it
yeah well you kind of you don't get one
without the other though you know um the
questions by themselves are just
questions and but if put the question
out there then you got a lot of audience
to have different answers yeah but
what's really important is providing
answers and then not just providing
answers but fi providing reasons for the
answers that you know so the process of
inquiry
um you know questions are what we begin
with they're not they're not what we end
with you know
um in in most things in in almost I mean
philosophy is probably more willing to
entertain questions than most
disciplines are academically most of
them want you to know what the the
answer is and how to find the answer
philosophy is one of the places where we
get to ask more questions you know and
in life most people are pretty impatient
with questions you find you know they
they really want they don't even want
answers they just want a procedure for
how things are going to happen you know
um so yeah philosophy is probably more
open to that but it can't just be asking
questions because then then people are
right that we're just kind of
bullshitting around you know um which is
the common complaint about philosophers
we never get anything
done so I mean Hume did you got a whole
book done and and and some other books
but you can say well what if the book is
wrong well I don't know how much of an
achievement it is then you know so any
other questions yeah yeah is there a
connection between
human oh yeah yes very much so um so
utilitarianism officially is this
movement that begins with Jeremy benam
right and then John Stewart Mill is like
the Next Generation very important
thinkers in the 19th century um Hume is
a big influence on benthem and Hume uses
the idea of utility which a lot of other
people were using at the time Adam Smith
you know the French uh encyclopedists
they're all appealing to this idea of
usefulness or utility and and measuring
it um Hume doesn't go as far as Bentham
does in terms of s systematizing that
but yeah benam is is uh really in a lot
of respects influenced by hum so I don't
know how I left that out but I'm glad
you asked because that is one of the one
of the big influences that he he had on
the world of ideas and if anybody you
know who doesn't know about
utilitarianism it was a massive
philosophical movement that is still
prevalent today in professional ethics
you know like if you're doing business
ethics utilitarianism is one of the main
approaches medical ethics people don't
like it because you know it has this
tendency of like leading to well what if
we Harvest this I'll actually I'll give
you a case um this is from the uh uh
famous trolley problem discussions so
the original trolley problem is not the
trolley going down the tracks and you
have a switch that you can pull and it's
going to hit five people if you if you
don't pull the switch it it you know it
runs over them otherwise it runs over
one that's only part of it and that's a
later
modification the original trolley
problem is this so you got a trolley
you're actually in charge of it uh it's
going to hit five people you can divert
it onto another set of tracks it'll kill
one person would that be okay most
people uh will say yeah that that's okay
to do because you're saving five people
at the expense of one it sucks that you
have to do it but you know um yeah
that's the right thing to do that's
that's a utilitarian way of looking at
it right and then
um there's another uh similar case where
people don't they're they're not as
happy about five versus one all right so
the other case is called
operation and there's a doctor and he's
got you know very much control over his
his Ward right so it's not like modern
medicine and he's got five sick patients
each of whom are terminally ill and each
of them has an organ that has to be
replaced or they're going to die so one
needs a heart two of them need lungs one
one lung each two of them need kidneys
right and in comes another patient who
just needs I I think if I remember right
it's like a flu shot or something and
he's like your organs are really nice
you know you're in good shape and he's
like he doesn't even ask the guy he's
like let me give you a shot some pet
some pet pills right and he he
tranquilizes him and then he Wheels him
in back and then he harvests him killing
the guy in the process right uh and you
know one kidney to this person one kid
now he's saving five people's lives
right that's good isn't it these people
would die otherwise but at the expense
of the one now most people would say
that's not okay right and so here's the
original trolley question why is it okay
to like divert the trolley but it's not
okay to cut somebody up for their organs
and stick them in other people that's
kind of a weird uh quandry and I mean
the the original writer of it um you
know maybe she uh she's overestimating
how many people say no in this case and
yes in this case but that that's where
it came in and that's all utilitarian
reasoning a strict utilitarian would say
hey they're the same Cas there's no
difference saving five saving one you
got to choose one or the other it's a
no-brainer right so in medical ethics
they don't like utilitarianism too much
even though medical decisions are often
made on utilitarian basis because we try
to you know make everything coste
effective right the hospital
administrators love utilitarianism
because it helps them keep the hospital
going uh but doctors usually don't like
it so much
um but yeah it's it's a really important
um uh not just um philosophical movement
but it has massive real world effects uh
what what often gets called effective
altruism comes out of utilitarianism
it's it's a movement that's been
tarnished a bit because some of the
people involved with it have like stolen
money and you know done things they
weren't supposed to do but that's
because they weren't good utilitarians
they weren't living up to their own
their own stuff and and to come back to
the question yeah Dave Hume is uh he's
influential on it he never formulates U
utilitarianism as such but he thinks
utility is something that um plays a
role in Beauty the usefulness of things
and in Justice you know so yeah good
good question any other questions
or are we still have a little bit of
time before they kick us out yeah yeah
um so I'm interested how long you've
been teaching Hume oh College setting
yeah um um that's a good question
so I think the first class that I taught
him
in it wasn't like an intro class it was
a philosophy of politics Law And Justice
class because he had ideas about the
social
contract and so I taught a little bit of
him in that class actually as a TA
teaching assistant before I started
teaching my own classes in an intro
class we had to cover here
but that was you know like the professor
would teach and then we would have our
small group sessions so you're you're
kind of like doing apprenticing and so
more than 20
years um I'd be hard pressed to say
exactly how
many um I
mean
CH oh
um I mean I never thought he was right
about a lot of the things but but I it's
not that My Views have changed like the
the is he right or is he wrong it's more
like I've developed greater appreciation
over time ra rather and part of that is
just personal change like I was rather
impatient with philosophers that I
thought were wrong right why would you
want to spend time on them then I'd be
like well it's kind of fun to read his
works you know you there there's even if
he's wrong about stuff he makes
interesting
arguments and you know going back to
like so my my students I I tell them in
all my classes you don't have to believe
any of this stuff you just have to
understand it well enough to be able to
talk about it competently on on you know
papers and tests right understanding
very different than agreement or
appreciation you don't even I tell them
you don't even have to appreciate it you
don't have to like these people you just
have to know what they what they say
because then I've got them right I
planted a seed and that can grow because
I know for me
man there's so many thinkers that when I
was a
undergraduate I thought they were stupid
I couldn't you know see why anyone like
them like Aristotle for
example um but then after a while I came
to realize that it wasn't Aristotle who
that there was a problem with it was I
was wrong and I there were roadblocks to
me appreciating him right um and so I
think with my students I don't expect
them especially because they're not
Majors right they're all other things I
just want to like put a couple seeds in
their head that maybe later on will will
germinate you know but you never know
what what that's going to lead to you
know see a lot of people not liking the
um lack of cause and effect thing yeah
that kind of goes against like the push
for you know producing scientific
results well that was in yeah when I was
studying psychology like 5 10 years ago
yeah it was not much not much anymore
about Freud and more so just like
results and this St stud you know you
can you can have a humean point of view
there were philosophers of science who
adopted hum's point of view and you can
still do science you just you know you
you you don't say that you've ever like
determined every anything once and for
all right so you can say well 99% of the
time that we do this turns out this way
and in Psychology that's pretty damn
good right because I mean psychology
experiments are like all over the map
compared to like physics where you know
we drop the pen it better fall each time
right um You can you can have a humi
point of view the what we call the
positivists um erns mock you know uh in
physics um AJ air in
philosophy um they um they used a humi
perspective and they were fine with it
but when you tell
people yeah the quality thing when you
suggest to them that once we get beyond
the realm of our experience we don't
really know anything um they don't like
that because that means we can't know
anything about God or about whether we
have a soul or not or you know all these
other big big things that people are
very invested in right so yeah I mean
hum is still viewed as like one of the
Bad Guys by a lot of people in the
present you know because of these these
views that he's
got so any other
questions yeah how does the
interpretation of
its ideas you all with time since you
have been doing for 20 years oh of
teaching you mean or Society has changed
drastically over the last 20 years yeah
and the interpretation sometimes is
really relevant to the time so how does
it well that's yeah that's interesting
um I mean I can say that pretty much all
the people who I typically teach remain
relevant throughout my lifetime and will
probably remain
relevant after I'm gone but the examples
that we use change considerably right
because when all of us were younger we
can remember a time where there was no
social media for example whereas these
these students who are 18 right now
they've that's their environment they've
never lived in a time where we weren't
connected with each other through the
internet you all these you know Myriad
ways that we can access on mobile
technology so I'll I'll use examples
like how do you know how your iPhone
actually works I mean or Android or
whatever whatever else you got right um
I don't want to like be prejudiced
against non iPhone users I just happen
to have an iPhone um so you know we we
we come up with like examples that fit
the time it's interesting too that you
bring that up so I used the word Spock
earlier right and I think everybody
knows who I'm talking about um the first
officer of the Enterprise in the
original Star Trek series you can't use
references to spock with 18-year olds
because they have no clue who the hell
you're talking about you couldn't even
use them 10 years ago they didn't know
who you're talking about right because
Star Trek for them is um peard and lower
decks and that new show that they've got
out that I can't remember of hand uh
it's not Enterprise it's another one
right um and and they may not have any
interest in it because our our society
when it comes to like viewing there's a
million options right whereas back when
we were young H you had your channels on
the TV then you got cable but everybody
was still watching the same shows right
um so you you have to you have to modify
the examples that you're using but the
basic ideas
um I haven't I haven't found anybody who
I've taught who I was like well now
they're no longer
relevant that I can remember I I might
be wrong about
that um but Hume certainly remains very
relevant you know maybe even more in
some respects like the animal issue I
think in our time the uh on the value
aspect interpretation oh how is my I I
hope my interpretation has gotten better
and more
accurate but uh you never know you would
need like an outside Observer somebody
else who knows Hume to watch you teach
and interact with students and say no no
you're getting Hume wrong right it's
very hard to be a good assessor of your
own um your own capacities that way
right do you want to try in about that
Andy because you know youve got a
background in faculty development you
know you are less rigid oh in your
response to question I think that to
your earlier point about the impatience
that you had with philosophers I think
that you had a certain amount of
impatience with um not a negative
impatience but certainly sort of a
practiced impatience with the questions
that people would POS okay I think the
fact that you do so much more public
philosophy work not just classroom
teaching yeah but public philosophy work
because I see this most in the amas or
the sessions that you host where like
anybody can chime in about anything yeah
um I don't want to say that you have
developed a capacity for kind of
suffering you know off topic or
inaccurate readings but you're far more
generous with it than you used to be I
think you try to build connection for
people who are clearly lacking either
framework or capacity or Foundation yeah
help bring them to at least a little bit
better of an understanding so you have
the ability to talk to people who are
well versed in something at a higher
level but I think you're also doing
doing a better job over the past 10
years of getting more people to connect
with topics where they may be yeah
grossly you know misunderstanding it or
really far apart from it I I think with
academic students one of the things that
to to go to your question that made a
difference for me was realizing that
um we only get a few chances to like you
I talked about planting seeds to ever
reach them right right because in our
society we don't generally have people
study philosophy if you're really really
lucky you might get it in high school as
an English elective or social studies
elective or religion elective but it
might be poorly taught as it was for me
when I was a kid um whereas in other
countries that's part of the curriculum
right um so we get them at Marquette for
one class and that's it used to be they
had to take two classes you know uh
philosophy of human nature and ethics
and I and they got rid of the ethics
requirement and now it's just this one
thing called foundations of philosophy
which is an intro class so this is the
one chance that I have to get the
business majors and nursing majors and
psychology majors and pick whatever you
know pre pre- pre-law Premed all all
these kids who are go-getter
professionals to read some philosophical
literature and take stuff
seriously getting them actually ask
questions is is tricky with this
generation they're they're often very
passive um compared to us I think right
um and and I yeah i' I've come to
realize that if I shut them down what
messaged at that s ah philosophers are
jerks why would I want to study this
crap you know it's not worth my time if
I say oh well you know um let's take
that idea and see what we can do with it
over here I mean it it shows the person
that I'm taking their ideas seriously
which makes them
feel hopefully good you know not anxious
or something what's he gonna do with my
ideas and then um maybe they get
something out of it you know and then
they instead of like going back to the
dorm and saying oh this this prick you
know my professor he humiliated me in
front of the class they're like hey I'm
taking this class and it's actually
pretty good I I still don't understand
David Hume but think I want to read him
a bit more something something like that
or Aristotle or Mary W stonecraft or
whoever right well any final questions
or yeah so obviously I'm biased right I
mean I hope so and we work together on a
lot of things so I I have Ops about Dr
that are I can say very freely um but I
think the thing is is that you also have
been able to connect curiosity because
it's not just marqu the my yeah and and
the ability to like build build that
idea of challenging uh and creating
analoges it's almost like what you see
in really good design thinking where you
help the student or the new person or
even the expert find an analog for a
tricky toic they can trouble with it in
ways that they can connect with it
relate to and understand so okay I think
that's an important distinction I think
analogies and examples are really really
important and teaching not just
philosophy but most things because most
of us get things by saying oh it's sort
of like this right
so I think that's that's good
pedagogy um any other questions though
or just back to your point about um
longevity and aging oh yeah so bill was
in a class called Aging Mastery which is
senior Cent had okay and so this was
like preo like seven years ago was one
of the youngest ones in the class didn't
I was goingon to say yeah um and so
there's different sections your health
like medicine you talk to your doctor
and and I think I don't know forgive me
here we'll have to bring up next time
what was the question but his answer was
having curiosity and how that can lead
to a healthy long life and you are just
epitome of it because as long as we've
known you and he knew you longer about
teaching philosopy to the pris U prison
um establishment students and now the
public and the YouTube which is all over
the world I mean just Stellar it's just
well thank you it's just yeah I mean I
there is one thing that I do suffer not
just professionally but also in terms of
like getting things done because I am
broadly curious you do better if you
specialize like just be a hum scholar
right because then you can like totally
get through all of his works but I'm
like scattered over a bunch of different
things which which is good because then
I can like draw connections but you you
always feel like I don't have enough
time you know to really get to the
bottom of of this or that so it's a
trade-off and there's no there's no
solution to that problem you know there
there's an old thing so we'll end on
this there's this uh old uh metaphor I
think Isaiah Berlin came up with it
called the Hedgehog and the fox are you
familiar with this one the Hedgehog you
know they basically just stay in one
place and they do what they do really
really well but they don't see the rest
of the world the fox wanders all over
the place they don't have like a a bod
uh but they get to see an awful lot of
stuff I'm I'm a fox I'm not a hedgehog
you know and you you kind of have to
pick one or the other um and you can't
be both at the same time I think um so
it's probably a matter of temperament or
something like that more than anything
else but there are a lot of hedgehogs in
uh in philosophy who are really really
good at what they do you know but they
only have like this little area of
expertise so than much you're you're
very welcome yeah and it's the same way
like in medicine right I mean any other
discipline you can only do so much
so you're welcome yeah thanks for
coming